i was trying to think of like what
what's a weird thing that a lot of
people do on youtube
to like youtube yeah just weird weird
stuff they might say
often that i'm trying to think well like
the whole thing of like
there's always that one comment in every
video which is like joey's not gonna see
this
he's not going to reply just because i'm
first in the comments section
and then i don't i don't know yeah i
don't know
i like and i'm tempted to comment to
prove them wrong but i'm like no yeah
that's what you want my no
no i'm going to fall into the back you
almost got me there i'm like you know
what no you are right i am not going to
see this [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you for thinking you're entitled to
my time
actually what i like to do to those
comments is like i just i don't even
heart it i just
like it so the only one that knows is
like that person
and they usually probably about being
like oh my god joey like my comment and
everyone's like no he did it
because there's no way to prove it
there's no way to [ __ ] prove it
but they get the notification being like
the anime man liked your comment
oh my
even if it's because i've been getting
like growing a bunch but i've just
noticed more a bunch of nonsensical
comments on my videos
like comments just don't relate to it
more like just people being like yeah
i'm i'm
why are tired certainly [ __ ] under my
void right like there's always ones as
well that are like
relating to other commenters they're
like oh i see that the guy with the
mustache is not in the comment section
did you ever get commenters that just
have a full-on [ __ ] conversation with
each other
in your in your comments yeah it turns
into a forum sorry i'm like damn this
video was ten thousand comments and you
look down at like five thousand of them
and just like so how you been
all right having like an msn messenger
chat or [ __ ] skype i'm like you do
realize this is what we have a discord
for right so that you can do that there
i saw one is this dude having like a
[ __ ] mental breakdown arguing with
this person being like
you're [ __ ] wrong you don't
understand the nuances and so on apply
to you okay and the guy
replied like honestly no not really i'm
glad that someone finally asked me
it's like a therapy session happening in
the comments i've seen those exact same
comments as well
it's like bro you okay it's like
honestly no i'm glad somebody finally
asked
i'm not okay and it's like what the [ __ ]
am i reading
how did this happen how did we get here
and i guarantee as well
the person who originally commented the
uok is just sitting there like
oh [ __ ] now i have to now i have to like
coach them through this like
or like when they're like whoa that's a
reference to x timmy minecraft and it's
like
what the [ __ ] is that like people will
comment be like oh this is a reference
to game grumps i'm like
they've have so many episodes they
probably said the whole [ __ ] yeah
they don't even like give the reference
like where it is right
no i don't know what i don't know who
this person is that you're telling me
i'm referencing
it's like it's like bro this is this
video is just a copy of minecraft player
i'm just yeah and i'm just like who and
then i look up the channel and they have
like 12 subscribers i'm just like
how the [ __ ]
what do you mean i copied them no one
could have copied them if they wanted to
because nobody saw the video
it's so true though because i think i i
i've this is the first time i'm hearing
that i thought i was the only person who
got those comments
referencing this random video or this
random youtuber that i've had
i have never seen before and apparently
you know you're just copying their joke
or yeah
the internet is massive people are going
to make the same joke eventually it's
going to happen
you know what type of comment i finally
just want to see gone it's the [ __ ]
nobody literally nobody joey
it's like i'm just letting you know guys
right now none of them are funny
i'm just saying that none of them are
funny none of them are unique
sometimes sometimes it's like one out of
like a thousand maybe
there are some videos where the comments
are just [ __ ] gold yeah and
but most most of the times comments are
just like this big circle jerk where
it's the same type of comment that gets
upvoted every time
and it's like the funniest comments in
my videos are always the ones that have
zero likes
and it's like why does this not have any
likes it's always the ones i heart as
well because i'm just like
here you go guys this is a funny comment
look learn from this comment
none of you guys are like this comment
i'll like it because this is some funny
[ __ ]
that you guys should be tweeting more
not the [ __ ] literally
literally nobody joey
i'm like do they have just like a copy
pasta ready for these comments yeah
just be like immediately be like a
semi-awkward moment or a funny moment
like
all right that's it that's it yeah
that's the one that's that's the thing
that literally nobody does yeah that's
it that's the one do you guys remember
the
era of youtube comments before they like
ranked them and it was just like
it was just going like a free-for-all
yeah it was just a free-fall that was
when
that was when youtube was a [ __ ]
cesspool oh yeah at least now it's like
somewhat organized um and it's just
basically become reddit in a way
but it's better than it's better than it
used to be i think i think though like
the funniest comment sections i always
see are like the at least with this year
right
it was all the comments on the [ __ ]
uh rose and big head episodes
yeah like that comment section i've
never laughed
that hard reading a comment section but
it's over from the night day it's 90
days beyonce episodes like the clips
because it's some of the meanest
comments that i've ever seen but
at the same time it is so funny i
realized watching reality tv shows like
90 day fiance
are so less fun when you can't read a
comment section oh yeah
cause like i tried watching the show
normally like a different season
and it was just not fun because every
time something really obnoxious happened
or one of them said something really
like just stupid yeah i wanted to
immediately go down to the comments and
say
yeah oh that's it right because you know
when you're watching a youtube video and
something happens you're like i'm going
to the comment section
yeah i want people talking about this i
missed it i don't get that when i watch
90 day fiance normally
yeah what i want to experience is what
it would be like if you had like whole
anime episodes
uploaded on youtube yeah what would a
comment section be like right well you
have control but crunchyroll's comment
section is like garbage
yeah i mean that that doesn't work
because like who the [ __ ] leaves a
comment on the crunchyroll
who does that who are you why are you
leaving comments on a crunchyroll
episode should people give in there like
they're like 48-hour
passes yeah it's just it's just like
work is add control
we're gonna fill this comment section
because most of the comments are just
like the gift passes
and then there's people that are
actually commenting on the episodes and
and i'm just thinking
man but it's it's so like non-stops it's
like very good episode
smiley face i think i went to girlfriend
episode one i think the comment was
god this is the trashiest show this
season i'll see you all next week
i thought that was a good comment but
that's that sounds like a youtube
comment though right yeah i mean that's
that's what i want i want youtube
comments in there yeah
there's something though about youtube
comments that just i don't want to say
it but
he's gonna say it he's gonna say it
like they're the most like i'm smarter
than you discussions yeah
oh yeah exactly yeah at least on youtube
everyone knows they're an ape
like no one tries to like yeah read it
reddit comments are the epitome of
um actually i love reddit but i hate
looking
past the meme oh yeah yeah sometimes
sometimes you'll see some funny stuff if
there's ever like a comment thread
that's
a discussion it's like the biggest
[ __ ] minefield
i've ever seen just a bunch of people
who want to validate their like
intelligence and it's just so sad and i
i can't read it i i
it's just pathetic half the time
sometimes there's really good threads
with really solid advice but most of the
time especially when it's like the
the argument threads yeah change my
opinion
[Music]
everyone posts to those subreddits like
am i the [ __ ] everyone who posts
that subreddit knows they're not the
[ __ ] except for like that one dude
that one dad who deleted this kid's
minecraft
of course you're the [ __ ] why did you
think you were
yeah so as a punishment this one dad on
reddit apparently thought it was a good
idea
because his kid wasn't doing work he
deleted his kids minecraft and all the
stuff that he built in it right
i went to reddit being like am i the
[ __ ] because i deleted my kids
minecraft account and all the
stuff he built and everyone's like yes
yeah of course you are yeah he's that
kid worked hard on that stuff
of course you'll be [ __ ] and it was
on like twitter and everything that [ __ ]
blew up
yeah that's that's like you know your
kid like building like an actual house
right like from the ground up and then
it's like
no i don't like the way you made that
room it just blows up the house
start again it's like 90 percent of
reddit is like very self-serving and
there's like 10
that's like a dumpster fire you're like
i want to watch oh yeah i mean i like
i enjoy reddit for the memes like the
like memes are great yeah the memes are
great and
whenever whenever there's like a good
meme thread or something
that's where i enjoy reddit i mean
that's why i like elsa yeah that's what
i like
right it's just
taste